president Trump's own Justice Department
accuses mr. Trump of directing illegal
payments during the 2016 presidential
campaign one top house Democrat says the
allegations could lead to impeachment
proceedings Special Counsel Robert
Muller and federal prosecutors in New
York released memos detailing evidence
provided by the president's former
personal attorney Michael Cohen Cohen
alleges he acted at the direction of mr.
Trump to pay hush money to two women who
claimed they had affairs with mr. Trump
Paula Reid is at the White House to help
sort all this out Paula what these
filings mean exactly for the President
and how's his legal team responding well
they've returned to a familiar playbook
attacking Cohen and the special counsel
just moments ago the president once
again tweeted attacking both Cohen and
the Special Counsel investigation but
the new details have been revealed in
these documents these present new legal
and political problems for the president
because here you have federal
prosecutors laying out in detail the
most direct evidence to date linking the
president to possible criminal activity
so now in addition to the special
counsels investigation into possible
obstruction or collusion the president's
own Justice Department is alleging that
he has committed campaign finance
violations prosecutors allege that he
was trying to secretly manipulate the
election by buying the silence of
alleged mistresses ahead of the campaign
and now you have to remember prosecutors
argue that this was all done in an
effort to influence the election and
because it was done secretly that's why
it's a possible campaign finance
violation John no doubt this will come
up at the Attorney General's
confirmation hearing some of you ask you
this Paul also the New York Times
reports federal prosecutors are shifting
their attention to whether the Trump
Organization played any role in the
campaign finance violations does that
indicate there might be others who are
part of this story other than the
president's lawyer well that's what
they're going to look into they're gonna
examine whether anyone else at the Trump
Organization had any knowledge of these
secret payments Cohen is helping provide
evidence that in this particular inquiry
remember the president has said that his
personal business that was a red line
that he did not want the special counsel
to cross so it'll be interesting to see
how he reacts to his own Justice
Department pursuing that same
of inquiry John fascinating thanks so
much Paula